hello guys
welcome to yet another video by simply
learn
i am keerthana and today we shall be
talking about
various data science roles and salaries
before getting into the video here's a
gentle reminder to subscribe to our
channel
and hit the bell icon so that you
wouldn't miss any update from us
so without further ado let's quickly
jump into the topic
today we shall be discussing data
scientist
data analyst business analyst
statistician data architect
and data engineer please note
that the list of various data science
roles is in no particular order
so let's get started data scientist
to become a data scientist you will need
to master skills in the following areas
programming master at least one
programming language
programming tools such as r and python
are
essential when performing analytics in
data
learn statistics probability and
mathematical analysis
as they play a significant role in
dealing with data
master the concepts of machine learning
and artificial intelligence
data visualization develop the ability
to visualize results
and then you will need to know data
manipulation and analysis
some other skills include intellectual
curiosity
business acumen interpersonal skills
and analytical and critical thinking
here are the roles and responsibilities
of a data scientist
as a data scientist you will be expected
to help
companies interpret and manage data
and solve complex problems data
scientists work
closely with business stakeholders to
understand their goals
and determine how data can achieve those
goals
they also design data modeling processes
create algorithms and predictive models
to extract the data for business needs
let's look at the average salaries of a
data scientist in
india and the united states according to
glassdoor in
india a data scientist can earn
approximately
10 lakh rupees per annum and about
113 000 dollars per annum in the united
states
up next in the list we have data analyst
here are the skills you will require to
become a data analyst
sql statistical knowledge
knowledge of programming data analysts
must have hands-on experience with
programming languages such as
python and r writing programs will help
you solve complex problems
critical thinking knowledge of data
visualization tools
a data analyst must create different
business reports using
several visualization tools
understanding of statistics and machine
learning algorithms
you must know concepts like probability
distributions
hypothesis testing etc some other
essential skills include
presentation skills microsoft excel
writing and communication skills coming
to the roles and responsibilities of
data and list
first and foremost a data analyst must
identify the organization's goal
they must assess the available resources
comprehend the business problem and
collect the right data
so a data analyst will be collecting
and interpreting data write complex sql
queries and scripts
to gather store manipulate
and retrieve information from relational
databases
data mining data is mined from many
sources
and organized to obtain new details from
it
by doing so data models are built to
increase the efficiency of the system
and then we have data cleansing data
examining
preparing summary reports and
collaborating with other teams
talking about the average salaries of a
data analyst in india and the united
states
according to glassdoor in india a data
analyst
can earn approximately 5 lakh rupees per
annum
and about 62 453 dollars per annum
in the united states if getting your
learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
next we have the role business analyst
the skills required for a business
analyst include
microsoft excel sql familiarity with
visualization tools
problem solving skills information
technology
analytic thinking and finally
interpersonal skills
to sum up you will need to have
technical skills communication skills
analytical skills decision making
capabilities
and managerial skills roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
initially a business analyst must
determine the kpis
that is the key performance indicators
a business analyst engages with existing
and prospective customers
and helps them adopt products and
solutions to meet business requirements
they ensure consistent growth in product
awareness
adoption and usage by customers
a business analyst also design solution
that best meets the client's needs
to sum up a business analyst's roles and
responsibilities include
market research data gathering data
analysis
communication documentation and finally
recommendations
talking about the average salaries of a
business analyst in
india and the united states according to
glassdoor in
india a business analyst can earn
approximately
6 lakh 65 000 rupees per annum
in the united states they can earn
approximately
68 346 dollars per annum
up next on the list we have statistician
the skills required for statistician are
mathematical ability and computer
literacy
a clear understanding of statistical
terms and concepts
like other roles in the list you will
require good written
and oral communication skills problem
solving skills and finally
high level accuracy and attention to
details
roles and responsibilities of a
statistician
the specific tasks that statisticians
are expected to complete
daily will vary and depend on the
particular
industry and organization in which they
work but some of the general tasks
include
consulting with clients and agreeing on
what data to collect
and how it should be gathered
considering any ethical and legislative
considerations
designing experiments collecting and
analyzing data
monitoring the data collected throughout
its shelf life
a statistician often carries out
research
and write reports and articles for
publication
let's now talk about the average
salaries of a statistician in india
and the united states according to
glassdoor
in india a statistician can earn
approximately
5 lakh 14 000 rupees per annum
in the united states they can earn
approximately
76 884 dollars per annum
data architects the skills required for
a data architect
include applied math and statistics
they are needed for data architect
positions due to analytical reasoning
computation interpretation and data
presentation
to solve business problems data
architects are expected to have a deep
understanding of data visualization
and data migration foundational database
skills are a must
too like any other job role in the list
data architects must have programming
skills as well
some other essential skills include
hadoop technologies
like hive mapreduce and pig machine
learning
data mining and modeling tools
let's now talk about the roles and
responsibilities of a data architect
data architects build and maintain a
company's database
by identifying structural and
installation solutions
they communicate with different
companies stakeholders to assess their
needs and goals
plan end-to-end model for data
consumption and analysis
working with the databases is a huge
responsibility for a data architect
as they monitor and maintain databases
data architects also preserve a
repository of all data architecture
artifacts let's now talk about the
average salary of a data architect in
india and the united states according to
glass door in india
a data architect can earn approximately
18 lakh 83 000 rupees per annum
in the united states they can earn
approximately
one lakh eight thousand dollars per
annum
at last in the list we have data
engineers
the skills required for a data engineer
are
sql it serves as the fundamental skill
set for data
engineers you cannot manage an rtb ms
without mastering sql
data warehousing is another essential
skill that helps data engineers
aggregate unstructured data collected
from multiple sources
data architecture coding
to link your database and work with all
types of applications
like web mobile desktop you must improve
your programming skills
the other essential skills are machine
learning
and apache hadoop based analytics
talking about a data engineer's roles
and responsibilities
they are expected to perform the
following duties
work on data architecture they use a
systematic approach to plan
create and maintain data architectures
while also keeping them aligned with
business requirements
collect data they have to obtain data
from the right sources
before initiating any database work
researching to address any issues that
can arise
while tackling a business problem create
models
and identify patterns and finally
automate tasks talking about the average
salaries of a data engineer in india and
the united states
according to glassdoor in india a data
engineer can earn approximately
seven lakh rupees per annum in the
united states
they can earn approximately one lakh
three thousand dollars per annum
and by this we reached the end of this
video
think we missed any let us know in the
comment section below
we'll be back again with yet another
informative video
till then stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here